the ongoing conflicts in Syria and Iraq
continue to attract growing numbers of
foreign Fighters many from European
countries the risks they pose notably
when they come back are a matter of
growing concern to all as President Van
rompe pointed out at the UN General
Assembly in our countries also
radicalization can strike anywhere we
need urgent Collective action to stop
these foreign fighters from joining isil
ranks aware of the dangers Associated to
radicalization EU home Affairs ministers
meeting in Luxembourg are set to discuss
how to accelerate the implementation of
measures adopted by EU ministers in June
last year to prevent the flow of foreign
fighters to better understand who these
people are and detect suspicious travel
and to provide the adequate criminal
justice
response once update dated on the
progress of the task force Mediterranean
ministers will also discuss how to
better manage migratory flows on the
basis of a paper prepared by the Italian
presidency which proposes three main
lines of action to go beyond the
immediate emergency response and provide
a more structured frame for Action
finally ministers will turn to data
protection and the so-called right to be
forgotten debate on this issue
intensified following the decision of
the European court of justice against
Google Spain in May this year the ruling
forces search engines to provide
citizens the opportunity to request that
information published about them on the
Internet be removed ministers are also
expected to close the negotiations on
chapter four of the regulation which
deals with controllers and processors of
personal
[Music]
data